منذ فجر هذا اليوم هناك محاولات تقدم
لقوات الاحتلال في عده محاور هنا في شمال
قطاع غزه بالتحديد
في باليه وايضا في المحور الاخر في
المناطق الشماليه الغربيه لشمال قطع غزه
بالتحديد منطقه العطاطه والسلاطين لكن
المحور المشتعل اكثر هو المحور الشرقي في
منطقه جباليا حيث تتمركز هناك قوات
الاحتلال والياته وجرافات الاحتلال في هذا
المكان حيث ضار بالتحديد في هذا المكان
اشتباكات ضاريه بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه
وقوات الاحتلال واستمرت للساعات حتى هذه
اللحظه منذ فجر هذا اليوم حيث كانت هناك
انفجارات ضخمه هزت هذه المنطقه نتيجه هذه
الاشتباكات بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات
الاحتلال ايضا على جانب اخر القصف لم
يتوقف باتجاه جباليه وباتجاه شمال مناطق
شمال القطاع بشكل عام من قبل الطائرات
الحربيه حيث استهدفت طائرات الاحتلال
المناطق الشرقيه ايضا لجبال وايضا منطقه
بيت حانون المناطق الشرقيه لبيت حانون
والمناطق الشماليه ايضا لبيت لاهيه وايضا
هناك قصف مدفعي متواصل خلال هذه
الاشتباكات لكن القصف المدفعي استهدف
منازل المواطنين في المناطق الشرقيه لجبال
ومنطقه السكه ومنطقه تل الزعتر هذا القصف
المدفعي يستهدف منازل المواطنين بشكل
مباشر ومستمر حتى هذه اللحظه في هذا في
هذه المناطق